It really started when I was about 13.
I was a junior high school student and,
um,
I met this librarian who's
kind of an eccentric person,
very well educated person,
and she,
we,
I used to hang around with my
delinquent friends in the library,
which tells you how eccentric
the librarian was because
that's not normally the
place where the delinquent kids hang out,
you know?
But she talked to us like we
were adults and that was a,
what would you call it,
a refreshing.
That was a refreshing experience.
And uh,
she knew that I liked to read and
she started giving me real books.
She gave me one day in the
life of Ivan Denisovich,
which was the first book published by
Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn in the Soviet
Union.
It's,
it's a story about the day
of a political prisoner in a,
in a,
in a work camp and brave new world and
1984 and animal farm and Ayn Rand's
books,
which was quite interesting because she
was the wife of our member of parliament
who was the only member of the
opposition in our province.
And he was a socialist and
NDP new Democratic Party
leader as a matter of fact.
And,
but despite that,
she gave me Ayn Rand's books because she
thought that I should be exposed to the
other side of the argument.
So I read atlas shrugged and,
um,
the fountain head and well,
she was the first person who
helped me discover literature,
let's say.
And while at the same time I got
interested in what had happened in Nazi
Germany.
Then I wrote an essay about that when I
was about 13 or 14 about Auschwitz and
what had happened there.
And I never read that,
really never left my mind.
I would say,
I think I read Viktor Frankl's man's
search for meaning at that point,
which is a book I would highly recommend.
I have a reading list on
my website by the way,
at Jordan B.
Peterson Dotcom.
And so there's a variety of books there
that have really influenced me and I put
them up for other people's,
um,
use.
Anyways.
I never,
what I learned about Auschwitz and about
Nazi Germany never really left my mind.
And because I couldn't understand
how people could act that way,
how they could not only be possessed
by an ideology to the degree that the
Germans were in a very civilized country,
Germany,
you know,
so it was,
I suppose even a more spectacular shock
that something so catastrophic happened
there.
There wasn't just the
ideological possession,
it was the cruelty and the gratuitous
cruelty in the service of that ideological
possession that I couldn't understand.
It didn't,
I couldn't establish a relationship
between my own being and,
and those patterns of action.
And as I got older,
that concern transformed
itself into an obsession.
I would say not so much with what
had happened to Nazi Germany,
but with,
I think what happened,
what was happening as a consequence
of the collectivist philosophy per se,
which you might think of something that
manifested itself both on the right in
Nazi Germany and then on the left in
all the multitudeness and catastrophic
communist regimes that characterized
the bulk of the 20th century.
And they're insane.
Murderousness and that probably
culminated for me in the 1970s when I Read
Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn
the Gulag archipelago,
which is another book that everyone
should read because in some sense it might
be the defining document
of the 20th century.
And the fact that everyone in the West
isn't familiar with that book is actually
a signal of our
catastrophic moral failing,
I would say.
Um,
I started writing this book called maps
of meaning in about 1985 although I had
been working on variants
of it before that.
And what I was trying to understand
was maybe the psychological
motivations for the Cold War,
something like that.
Many of you are old enough to remember
what it was like in the 1980s we just
went and visited the house in,
in Reykjavik where
Gorbachev and Reagan met,
which was quite something to see.
And when they decided they were going to
bring at least some of the insanity to
irrelative halt,
thank God.
And the 80s were a very contentious time.
You know,
the Cold War sort of peaked in two at
two times a peaked in 1962 during the
Cuban missile crisis.
I don't know if you know this,
but I w I visited a uh,
nuclear missile site in Arizona
both 10 years ago.
It was a decommissioned missile site,
intercontinental ballistic missile,
intercontinental ballistic missile is
a very large rocket and can go halfway
around the world and its ballistic,
which means it has the
same function as a bullet.
And the bullet is ballistic
because once you fire it,
it's gone.
You don't control it after it.
It leaves.
So once you launch a ballistic missile,
it's launched,
there's no calling back.
And they told us they
did a simulation launch,
which was very eerie thing.
And so to launch a nuclear
missile is a big console.
It sort of looks like the star
Trek control a control module,
let's say.
And One person stands here.
One person stands about 20 feet away,
each have a key around their neck
and they put the key in the lock
simultaneously and then turn it for 10
seconds and at the end of 10 seconds the
missile is gone.
And that's that.
And they both had their
keys in the lock in 1962 so,
and we came close again in 1984 when,
I don't know if you know this,
but there's Soviet missile
detection system signal.
The launch of four or five missiles
from North America and a single Russian
soldier decided that it was a false
alarm and refuse to push the button that
would have resulted in major retaliation.
He just died about a year ago.
You can read about him on Wikipedia.
Anyways,
I read soldier Nixon in 1970s and,
and I made me,
me even I would say more obsessed
with what was happening in,
in on the world stage.
I was trying to understand why it was that
the systems of belief that we inhabited,
let's say one typifying the Soviet
Union and in similar states,
Maoist China,
North Korea,
wonderful places like
that versus the West.
We each had our own way
of construing the world,
the ways of construing the world
were set at odds with one another.
And the fact that they were set at
odds with one another appeared to be so
significant that we'd armed ourselves with
50,000
yeah,
hydro hydrogen bombs on each side,
something like that.
And I don't know how much
you know about hydrogen bomb.
You know,
you know about atomic bombs,
you know that a hydrogen bomb has
an atomic bomb for the trigger,
right?
So,
so like the atom bomb that
was dropped on Hiroshima,
that was something that
was a fission bomb,
not standard atomic bomb,
the first generation,
but hydrogen bomb is incontestably
more powerful than that.
And we were producing them
in the tens of thousands.
It's not like we don't have any now,
but it was really some insanity in the
1980s and people seem to have a very
itchy trigger finger.
So I was very confused
about this in two ways.
One from a psychological perspective,
because by that time I had just studied,
decided to study psychology
instead of political science,
which was my original major.
I get,
I got disenchanted with political science
because I didn't believe that people
were fundamentally motivated
by economic issues.
I still don't believe that that's true.
They're motivated by whatever
they're motivated by.
It can't be captured by economics,
not,
not precisely.
It's very curious about what it was that
was so important about a belief system
that people would risk putting the
entire planet to the torch to ensure that
their particular mode of construing
the world prevailed was an interesting
psychological problem.
What was so important about belief
system that would justify destroying
everything,
let's say,
or risking destroying everything,
because that was certainly the
situation we put ourselves in.